hi everyone all right my uh screenshot
uh hi everyone as mentioned before i'm
going to talk about some of the common
mistakes that i have found in ef core
uh lots of pain that i have gone through
it uh
looking at underscored and trying to
figure out why is it slow and
kind of also address
one of the issues that some people may
have regarding ef core
saying uh it's slow we shouldn't use
that um in fact a lot of issues
that i have found is basically just
misunderstanding of how ef core works
and with some of the tweaks sometimes i
got even up to 100 times uh performance
improvement just to add a few things
so hopefully what we're going to see is
uh some of the issues that you might
have in your project you can then
fix them up a little bit and bang you'll
get a lot of performance uh back uh also
better memory and in the end what is
even more important better stability to
your application uh because the
application no longer needs to work as
hard as it did before
all right so a quick introduction uh
for myself i mean in a kafka you can
just call me jk uh i'm solution
architect at ssw an ai microsoft mvp
you can follow me on all of these uh
socials
um i'm also organizing a couple of a
couple of meetups like apec ai global ai
podcast the full snake brisbane user
group
and predominantly i'm a.net core and ef
core developer
i'm also doubling in the ai but this is
my main uh
main thing that i do every day and
i really like to perfect my art and this
is why i have focused quite a bit to
figure out what are the actual best
practices for ef
core
now
um
why i like to use ef core uh is
one of the
big
reasons for it is basically you get a
nice balance between features you get a
good flexibility as well as performance
anyone who looked at how ef core have
developed since
the start of 1.0 all the way to ef core
six they can tell you it's not just if
we're getting a lot of features with
every single release every single
release brings us also a lot of
performance improvements which
ironically means that some of my slides
might actually no longer be relevant in
say ef core seven maybe microsoft will
say okay too many people have issues
with that one maybe we can solve the
problem for them so that's one really
cool thing about ef core on top of it
you can switch between different
databases and in my opinion um it's
really really good for relational
databases
not just because you have joins and
they're pretty performant
you can also switch between different
database engines so you're not stuck
with just one
engine
oh and
we can't forget about migrations
database scan folding and there's a lot
of tooling around ef core which is why i
really love ef core
and if you have any issues and you're
thinking about hey we might need to
switch to something else because of
performance issues or something like
that hopefully this is going to help you
stay on track
all right so one of the motivations of
why i wanted to build this is basically
a lot of issues that uh people
complained about that i have seen saying
hey this is running slow uh was uh were
very easily fixed
uh another thing that i also found is
that
when i fixed those issues the code
actually looked much more simpler much
more straightforward and people could
read it more easily which was ironic
because we actually make it more
performant yet it's more maintainable
and more readable than the original code
so sometimes
optimizing a code isn't a bad thing
and uh sharing the best practices um and
those back practices are going to be
backed by uh benchmarks and tests so you
can actually not just see the numbers uh
most of them you'll be able to just pull
my github and try to replicate uh that
for for yourself
and lastly
i had some scars regarding ef core and
what i've seen and i hope that i'll
never need to see them again
all right so test methodology for this
was i used at the beginning a batch um
benchmark tool called benchmark.net
mostly for consumption
memory consumption especially at the
beginning of those more
horrendous
queries to just show you that yes
actually it has a huge impact
especially when your database starts to
grow
um then
most of the tests are going to go
onwards with bombandi which is kind of
like a simple load testing tool you can
say i have five active connections and
for 60 minutes try to make as many
requests as possible so we have a little
bit more
um
real performance information we don't
just get one hit and then see how uh the
database and our application behaves we
actually are
hitting uh the service a little bit for
a minute to see
whether the performance gets worse
over time or we have a stable
performance
then i also use postman
for that and doing one hit
queries and also most of the examples
that they do return back uh the actual
sql statement that was executed so that
we can compare
uh what is actually executed on sql
server for each of the cases
and all of these samples are in dotnet 5
and ef core 5
because i started this demo about
three months ago four months ago and i
really wanted to
um show one of my clients hey this this
are the the issues that we're having and
here are the better examples of how to
do
it all right and also this is my machine
in case you're interested what is the
performance metric for my uh what what
hardware am i using to do all of this
performance test the sql server is on my
machine as well as the application so
that might not be the best perfect
testing machine for for doing that
but i think
what i have tested in production it's a
good enough indication to tell you which
code is better than the other
all right so for the test data i have
downloaded from this link
and this test data has some simple
tables like customers employees products
and sales the most important one is the
sales which have 7 million cells in it
just to drive home
what can happen
when you write a math code
and then the database starts to increase
in size then all of the sudden something
that was okay in performance when you
develop the application when you push it
to production a few months later
suddenly the the entire website doesn't
work anymore and i'll show a few uh
pitfalls that i actually found
in actual production that caused the
entire website no longer working
all right so
one of the common mistakes that we'll uh
look at uh today is going to be going
from i credible to innumerable i'll show
you some of the pitfalls uh when you do
this kind of casting
uh then not using s not tracking uh you
might note that ef core
when you get data from the database
they're trapped and with snow tracking
uh you can make them not not tracked
and we'll see the impact uh of that
then getting all data when it's not
needed
sounds obvious but in a lot of cases
uh obvious doesn't seem to be enough
um explicit joins uh there are sometimes
really good uh when you do the queries
you do not include included additional
tables
but they can backfire and i can show you
how you can
avoid those issues
then we're going to have pagination that
is also very common issue that they have
found with pagination just when
implemented correctly
uh and lastly over complex queries are
going to sprinkle a lot of wisdom all
around
the session but these are the main
points that we're going to go through
and you know when
when i first started doing ef core and
when people say look you can quickly
screw up with um quarries i was thinking
how bad can it be and for years
that kind of was in my back of my mind
but in the last two three years i really
started to look into okay how bad can it
be in let me just say that sometimes
some
questions
shouldn't have an answer
and you know
this might be one of those
and
let's start with something very innocent
counting
you would say
well yeah we have here an example that
is obviously horrible right
we have
naive count we have here the table sales
then we do two list and then count
i have seen this in production
but you know it's an easy fix you just
remove two listings done right
but there is one less obvious one
so here
we have an again sales table
but we say i save it under a variable
which is i innumerable
and then we can't
now
conventional
wisdom considering how c works
would be that
they should be fine right like it's
innumerable so when you did.com
obviously it's going to execute on the
database right
well they're kinda the same thing
so
when you run this as an innumerable
you are getting all of the data from the
database
so this is one thing that was pretty
interesting uh to find out
um so yeah when you cast uh to
enumerable from that point onward
everything is in memory
and there's also the problem of knee if
where
or anything that actually has a method
like this over here where you return
you're basically returning a table but a
table
is not i variable
is i innumerable
uh and now you can start to think about
wait we have used repository patterns
and they are returning i innumerable and
then you start to think
oh
all of the data we're trying to get from
the repositories
we're getting all of the data from the
from the database without filtering
first and then we're filtering in
in
in memory and then you're starting to
realize
how many places you have performance
issues so
in what i innuenable is one of the
issues that i found to be the biggest
performance and memory issues in most of
the applications and you should avoid
them as much as possible if you do
a repository pattern maybe consider
using i queryable uh for the methods
that you know that they're going to be
filtered on a higher level i credible is
not linked to ef core
so if you have a different
different database engine you'll still
be able to use i credible uh despite
you know making that uh giving you the
ability to actually change uh what is
going to be current in database
so what's going on so why is this a
problem well first we download the
entire database obviously but this other
issues as well so because if core
supports entity tracking what happens is
that all of these entities are being
tracked and in order to make them track
it concerns a little bit more cpu and it
consumes a bit more memory
uh and then once we get all of that data
we're processing them in memory
uh we're doing the filtering we're doing
selecting order by and all of that stuff
we're doing on the dotnet application
rather than on sql server
and if that's not issue enough in the
end of the day we also need to run all
of this data through garbage collector
so garbage collector now has to do a lot
more work than it would
be necessary uh if we wouldn't
need to process everything in memory if
everything would be on sql server
and just to give you a
feel for uh
for skill so for instance if we have
seven million rows and each of them have
five integer
that on its own is already 140 megabytes
of data you're downloading from sql
server
that's already
a lot on its own and we're talking five
integers we're not talking about taxed
and other things
and tracking also adds about four bytes
per property uh per row although i found
that uh that metric might not be correct
i'll need to double check on it but at
least it seems to be four bytes per
product property per row as far as
understand it the minimum consumption
would be 218 megabytes per call and now
imagine you're trying to count all of
the
uh sales and that takes 280 megabytes
uh to count all of that browse and it's
quite a lot
and also it's slow and uses a lot of cpu
now this simple solution here is very
simple you change from i innumerable to
like variable and this actually prevents
the query to be executed in memory and
gets executed to sql server
and to go back to how bad
can this be
now if you have a small database
it's probably going to be a difference
in couple of milliseconds
here we have seven million uh rackets
so yeah we can see here naive count
takes just about
3.6 seconds
um
and takes i think this is about two
gigabytes of ram
um
now this is not a perfect test
especially for a location because
um
what
the
net benchmark is doing is
is running the test multiple times and
i'm trying to create and dispose ef core
and some of the memory of the previous
execution may bleed into the next test
so it may not be the perfect task but
you can see here
that the difference between the
uh the one that we did with ike variable
versus i innumerable
the difference in memory is massive it
you cannot even compare this
this is like 100 000 times larger
and
you know well performance is great to
have
faster and faster execution
uh which here you can see that it's
basically 63 times faster
i think the most important metric here
is that you
you don't consume all of the ram on your
net application
and similar thing here for um doing the
weight loss
um
innumerable versus iquarible uh
obviously the performance is hundred
times faster
as i promised you we're going to look at
things that makes hundred times faster
and changing from high innumerable to
high credible is one potential candidate
to increase before performance uh even
in the scales 100 times
and you can see here that allocation is
also
a massively smaller than what we had
before
and
you know to just drive the point here i
used bombandia and i'll show you example
how i used it
um
to basically load balance this for a
minute with five connection uh as much
as it could and the results that i got
is that the
naive count actually managed to do only
0.1 requests per second
and
it totaled with 10 responses for five
connections constantly pinging uh for
one minute so that is actually pretty
terrible response time
uh compared to that uh when we have
improved it we're just changing
innumerable to arc variable you can see
that all of the sudden in one minute we
got one more than thousand requests back
and the request per second uh increased
almost 18 requests per second so the
increase is massive
all rights
so let me before i switch to this let me
show you
in the code how this actually looks like
so over here
i have the worst case scenario
um
so
over here what i have done is i used iq
variable for this but i could use an
innumerable
and for the result
uh i used
a two list done mine tag with context
for now you can remove it just to not
confuse anyone
uh i did
to list and then
count so this is going to cause a
performance issue and here the query to
uh
twos query string i use this this is an
extension method to ef core
where you can convert a ike variable
into the actual sql statement that it
would execute
there's one caveat to this
is that you cannot do against count uh
first of default
um
income max and couple of others where
you actually need to execute the query
so this uh to query string um is not
going to
you're not going to be able to do it
against first of the fault and those
kind of things it's basically almost
expecting it to be a list
so that's one one issue with that but
you know it's good enough for our case
and what i have here is the application
running
i'm going to restart it just for sake of
argument
and what i'm going to do is let's clean
this up
just to show you what i'm doing
is i'm going to
take
the name of the controller
which is examples
pound
slash
and this is
west
case
and i'm going to bring up
my uh
task manager so here we can see that we
have zero percent 300 megabytes on
windows terminal
so when i run this
you will see that
cpu usage jumps significantly
the ram usage jumps significantly
and this is now happily processing
behind the scenes
so we went for
10 more seconds
and we should get results by the way if
you're interested about the bum bandit
tool
let me get the
browser over here
you can get it
on the github page
bombandir
uh from cote sandberg
bombandia and it's a really good um
really do a good tool for you to
benchmark
things a little bit more organically
than you know
hit with the postman and see what's the
result
now this takes a little bit of time
after it finished because it waits for
all of the requests to finish so you can
see that
it takes a long time to just finish off
everything
oh now it went to 17 gigabytes
this is
this is why you try to avoid innumerable
or too list prematurely
okay this may take a while
is it because
i interesting why is edge using that
much
okay usually take that took a little bit
faster
anyways i'm trying to show the point and
i think i got my point here um usually
it finishes much sooner than this
but i'll kill this because
it takes way longer than usually does
and what i also
hmm
[Music]
okay bring the stamina completely frozen
that's all right i'll just kill that
kiln that
all right so here we can see zero
that's wrong
i have tested this right before doing uh
this test
um anyway so i'm going to run this and
i'm going to show you in postman
over here
um there's a few things that i have done
uh when we run this
um when i do one request and by the way
you'll be able to get this all in the
github
when we
run this this is going to also respond
with a specific request
with a specific answer
and what i'm doing is when i'm getting a
response i'm actually using postman
to show
the result in a little bit more stylized
way with a visualizer
so hopefully yes we finally got a
response for the worst case now when i
visualize
this is the query that's been executed
on the sql server
now if we do the best case which
basically means as we're using i
variable
we can see here that the query changes
so let's visualize this
so you can see that instead of doing the
proper select statement we just have
select count
from sales
and then as as but that doesn't actually
matter
so the major difference here is if we
scroll down a little bit further is that
i adjust the account and that's it
all right let's go back to the slides
hopefully that comment here is not going
to cause too much problem because i
wanted to show some of the performance
uh
uh issues that i haven't put into the
slide but we'll see as we can get to
that
now another thing that you might want to
consider is as not tracking
now as no tracking what it does is it
excludes tracking on the entities uh and
that results in using less memory less
cpu usage
and those
entities are not tracked now that means
that you cannot update or delete
unless you retract them now if you track
them again manually
uh all your properties might be uh
marked as changed and then if you do an
update it will update everything so
maybe not the best thing to do so just
use s not tracking when you want to get
read only data
but the impact of doing that is pretty
significant
now i don't usually see this
much performance improvement uh here we
have literally five times faster
performance and we even uh use that full
time
less
memory than the uh test than the initial
uh code which the only difference is
that we added dot s not tracking
but
what they have seen in practice is that
you get at least 33 percent uh better
performance
and you get at least 50 percent uh more
uh less memory consumption so if you
can
if you can just have the data
speed only do use as no tracking it's a
one-liner that can give you huge
performance benefits
so here you can see that we have the
same method without snow tracking uh we
got about a hundred requests per second
we did the same which just adding as no
tracking
and we ended up with four times better
throughput
than with without it so it's a very easy
way to get better performance
another issue very common issue that i
have found
is also using explicit includes uh that
means that you have that includes and
say we're getting the customer table
now one of the issue that i found found
with this is
they usually put it into a method
uh they say okay this uh say the sales
table includes includes all of the
tables because you just want to make
sure that all the table is that you
might need are there
but that is a terrible thing because
even if you don't need that data even if
you do mapping and you don't use
any of that data
it will generate a sql statement that
will include the uh all of the tables uh
in your joins so you have now an
unnecessarily complicated query
and to solve this is for instance over
here we have a uh include over here and
we're getting all of the data
uh for that sales person and then we are
separately doing the mapping uh from the
um
from the
full sales
table with the salesperson
now alternatively you can actually uh do
the mapping in the database and as an
added benefit
you can directly reference the seals
person that first
name
and that will result in a implicit join
uh that means that as you can see here
i'm actually not using any includes
and if i uh
if there's any spec change then
actually we don't need to have the sales
person first name or things like that
um and we no longer depend on the
salesperson once we delete them
from
uh this mapping
we suddenly have no no joins in our uh
sql statement so you don't have to
constantly think about am i using and
include too often which
have pretty significant performance
benefit performance impact
you just have you can just forget about
it
one note however for this one is
if you practice
as a method
you need to do it as an expression of a
function
if you just
do
as a regular mapping
thing let me show you as an example say
we
we go to the weight loss
and
let's just take
this one here
let's say that we do not uh select
x
new uh
rdc cells yes so that's the
sales
model
and let's just say that we what we're
trying to do is we're trying to get
quantity
equal x quantity
we want to do cell idx sale id
and then we want to do product name x
product name
it's going to be product dot product
name
and let's just say that we are returning
sales model
let's just simplify this and i'll just
going to put
over here we don't need to complicate
things
and
just bear with me for a moment
so here we have a simple example of how
we did the mapping and what you can do
is you can actually
the control
r
m
or you can do
control dot
control dot and then extract it as
method
and what you'll notice here this is an
expression
so this is going to be executed on your
server
now if i do the similar thing
but instead of this
i'm going to do
this so i'm going to return the sale
model
and this is going to be x
i already have an x
and i use
map in memory
i use this instead
let's do this
this is now going to be processed in
memory so everything after this
is actually going to be in memory
i'm sorry
not in memory uh there's a different
trick
in later ef core actually this is
executed in the server side
but you will lose this mapping over here
so this is going to result in null
um so
because
you can get only the actual uh seal
table sale entity
it will not know
that you actually also want to have a
reference to the product table and this
mapping over here is going to fail
whereas in this case
where we're returning back an expression
it will understand oh wait you're
referencing product uh so i should
also do an implicit join to this product
so this is one of the common mistakes
that i have seen and that resulted in
ugly code uh that is absolutely not
necessary uh this looks
pretty nice to me and it's reusable so
you can use it in different
queries
and also very performant because
you only get the data you need
i've already done the nammer
and also the performance impact i kind
of forgot to add the performance impact
on this but
uh let's do this
um we have
here did i forgot to add the misc okay i
did forgot
uh but uh the performance impact here
i know i have here sorry
so the worst case scenario here would be
that
we include everything
so if we go back to the example joints
and we got for the worst case scenario
worst case scenario is
we're trying to get everything
uh and this everything result
results in
it can run the application first
i need to fix this first
i think everything
joy of doing everything uh live
so i think i can just do that and dot
com that was the original
code
i should be able to run
the impact of this is going to be that
before running
just make sure okay it's just not
putting it in the foreground
the impact of this is the worst case
scenario is going to obviously take a
long time to run
but if we look at the
um query you can see that we have all of
the inner joins that we have specified
but if we look at what we're actually
using we can see that we're only using
the sales person we're not using the
product we're not using the customer but
we are still executing all of these
queries so right now it was 6.4 seconds
if you run this again it's going to be
slightly better i think because that was
a cold boot
yeah 4.6 but it's a horrible performance
um now you can
it's not necessarily a bad case i would
discourage you from using this
you can
add the include
in the query and that's going to improve
the performance significantly so that's
only two seconds
um
but if i do
this again
it's going to result in exactly the same
problem as we had before
it's not going to improve performance
even though we're not using that table
now the time that you actually do want
to use
include
is when you're updating the uh
the elements so for instance i want to
get
all of the sales
for this salesperson
saying we got lists
and we do
wait query dot
uh to list
and then
i actually want to update
are you complaining
does not contain definition
interesting
new one uh
list
is it because i'm reusing it
i didn't have my morning coffee
but at async
so
when you're in situation where you
actually want to uh
do this and what you want to do is for
instance you
want to go
let's say first one and then you want to
go
to the
uh
sales person and then update some of the
information
of that person
then in that particular case you do want
to do include because
uh all of that is going to be tracked
and when you do
the
db context
maybe context
dot save
changes
uh that is going to be updated as well
so the included uh
tables are also being tracked and you
can update them just fine
now here it wouldn't update because we
have asthma tracking so in that case you
would need to do
um
with no tracking and for instance if i
do
change the name to be
uh jk
that should work just fine
what are you complaining now is seeing
method not accepting
ah because i need to
yeah now it works
if i run this
even though this is um this is a
included uh table it's going to update
so this is one case where you actually
do want to have include
just to show you the best case scenario
which is with the implicit uh join
if you run this
this is not only going to
ask me to run this
it's not only going to uh give you
a much more efficient
sql statement so here we're not only
efficient with the
joints we're also efficient for what
we're asking for and if you're
interested at the end i can show you
that
uh reducing the number of uh items
you're getting from the database
actually impacts the performance
so
you can uh
this is kind of almost double
performance gain
and
to uh in my eyes it's actually more
clear what you're trying to do here you
can see it's very clean uh i can
here i note that
this is only read-only data we're
filtering but that and we want to have
it in this shape so in my opinion that
is actually a much more cleaner code
it's very concise
and as a bonus it's high performance and
it has its very memory efficient so for
to me this is a win in all regards so
usually what they tell you is don't do
premature optimization
this would be the exception of this
there's almost no
side effects of doing this
all right so the next thing that there's
a common uh issue that i found is the
pagination
uh usually uh it happens because
um
what we're trying to do is filter data
we uh get the filter data so we do it to
uh to list and then we come them uh
already and only after that
we apply tag it take in skip and some
developers do that because they don't
know they they can use ikvarable to
their advantage
so for instance if we go to the
pagination controller
uh the common mistakes that we have over
here
so this is the worst case scenario here
we have the query uh we did the filter
now
what i have seen and this is a very
common scenario uh you wouldn't believe
how many times this happens is
we got all of the data
which is not too horrible because we are
filtering first
but what happens then is
we're using uh
that data to in memory process
um additional things like skipping the
page uh taking um
taking a slice of the results and then
mapping it
just so that at the end we can use
dbresult.com
so that we can actually get the right uh
number
of results so that we can then also show
the right number of pages and stuff like
that which
may look as a reasonable code
but a much better approach to this is
leverage the ike variable
here we have the query we do the same
thing as before
but what we do is we make a separate
request with this like variable
to count everything
so what that means is we are telling the
database that i want to have um i want
to know all of the results based on this
filter over here
and then what we do is we
basically do the imagination so we skip
a couple of items we take couple of
items
and then we
make another request to the database
to basically get that one slice of data
that we're interested in
now
this sounds like it should work worse
because we're doing two requests into
the database
but one interesting thing here is that
it actually is the reverse so if we do
the worst case scenario
we can see over here we have a very
simple uh request we have one join so
that's not interesting
but what you may find is that this takes
about two seconds to run
but if we do in the database for
instance
we end up having
a bit more code
but
so you can see here we have a bit more
variables and stuff like that but what
you can see here this takes only
127 milliseconds
this is on a completely different
ballpark so don't feel uncomfortable
doing uh small calls to the database
they can actually be a significantly
better way of getting data than trying
to get a lot of data from the database
and then process it in in memory
yeah
so i'm i'm just going to jump in a
little bit
we're coming up
on time and
honestly i could have i could leave you
go for like the next um however long
you've got left because like this is
really
interesting really
a really good look at um a bunch of
stuff so
um
i i guess
my first question is what's your what's
your next big tip for people um that are
wanting to to learn about some of these
common mistakes yeah so let me there's
two big tips one would be
um
the uh the thing with over complicated
uh queries and yeah uh apologies for
that i
was thinking that i don't have enough
content but i end up having too much
um we all have been in that space
um so one thing that and this is all on
github and i have done some performance
benchmark and i'm going to improve them
but one thing that i learned is
um
there is a thing where you can actually
split split queries into multiple ones
there's a feature called split queries
the sun caveats to it unfortunately
don't have time to get into it
uh where it allows you to split up the
queries into smaller queries for
instance salesperson there might be only
one and it will carry only one sales
person uh instead of duplicating
multiple ones in the same row that saves
you a lot of store a lot of transfer and
also a lot of sql server uh process but
you can also do it manually which i
found to be almost two to three times
faster than sql server uh sorry and then
ef core which is but it's very simple
you just query the person ahead of time
and then query all of the data that you
want for that person and then uh just a
simple for for loop uh you join those
data together and this is like two three
times faster if you struggle with
performance in this particular case
another thing that i
want to
say
oh yeah go okay one last thing
yeah cancelable queries so this is very
important uh you may see that i'm doing
in the
request i'm doing cancellation
token
and i'm including those translation
tokens indeed to list in the save
changes in first of the full async and
the reason for this is
if you cancel your cr your http request
the this cancellation token gets
cancelled and if you
if you don't um
listen to this cancellation token uh
what happens is the sql server will
still go on so if you have that count
example where it took six seconds to
process this six seconds still going to
happen in sql server yeah oh that's
that's a really good tip i i never
thought to capture the cancellation
token of the http request and use and
kind of passed that um especially as a
kill code through to your underlying
database um calls as well
just before we
we uh wrap up with you oh oh i see that
there's the the ads um
so the links to your demos um i did have
someone ask a question that i also was
wondering the answer to
the implicitly include stuff um is that
new to entity framework because because
i always remember
the problem with the implicit include is
that
uh most people um
use them in practice so for instance
they did the manual mapping and the
manual
so
they did the mapping and they did the
mapping say
cell model
uh map
cell right
so they did this
which is wrong
uh and this caused the implicit mapping
to not work uh if you struggle to uh to
figure out how to do this just make the
selection do control dot
and
basically introduce
why don't you want into just a method
anyways
usually it gives you the intelligence to
introduce
a method
and that is the right
way of doing it
cool well um excellent thanks for that
like they said that was really really
excellent and i i loved how you stepped
through all the demos and kind of broke
each um step down piece by piece because
that um and that i i was able to really
follow along um how how you kind of got
to each step of the process and how you
uncovered um the different changes that
happened along the way um but
unfortunately we are we are just about
out of time um and it is
it's coming up to lunch at least here in
sydney i know that you're in brisbane
and you're like lunch that's still at
least an hour away
but i'm going to invite uh lars back to
the stream
you